Rulers are often close, power moves from one person to another to form a smooth rule
Not only with kings or dictators, but also with representatives in democracy.
Families transfer power, or compete with other families for a role in power, much more than an opportunity.
The ruling dynasties seem normal, they may not be paying attention
But you should consider them if you want to understand and take power for as long as possible.
Even if you follow the rules of the rulers we discussed:
... transfer power switches, secure the treasury, control the elimination: no man governs forever.
The dictators with abundant resources and undisputed power still Fannie.
Representatives (Democrats) have to deal with death both literal and political.
But no matter what kind of ruler you are, your keys (Moedink), care about their wealth.
They keep you in your position, not your love in particular, but for the rewards they offer, in general.
But dead rulers can not distribute wealth.
So as your death approaches. Your supporters will feel nervous.
Your inevitable death will force your keys (moyedic) to plan to replace you, ...
... not only to preserve their wealth, but also because the sudden death of the ruler without planning will result ...
... to scramble for power at best, and a bath of blood at worst, ...
... leaving many keys (moyedon) inside now, then abroad.
That is why, if you are sick, keep your illness secret:
If your keys (Mooi) think you might die, they should start planning for the next ruler to avoid this.
Which makes even rumors about the ruler's health ... scary.
Whispers about your health are poison to destabilize the minds of your supporters, and it is almost impossible to remove it.
For keys, your replacement is inevitable anyway, so why not start planning sooner. Only for warranty.
Thus after a rumor, the keys may seem on your side in their business, ...
... but you are already dead in their minds.
You've lost control and will lose your throne, sooner than you want.
But while you can not defend against the King of Death or the extraction of poison from the minds of your supporters:
Is there a way to defend your authority in this world of rumors of your death to the other.
Mohammed. Muhammad is the answer.
Dictatorships and democracies have a lot of family rule, because the main supporters want it.
As your limit or your death is approaching, your family is there, willing to keep running the power conversion mechanism:
... continue to raise the treasury, keep the keys quiet and free of plots.
Surely the affectionate ruler may want to give advantages to their families, ...
... and being a regent comes with so many ...
... but the main supporters also want a ruling family in positions of power because ...
The family that conspires together, govern together.
The power of generations: Beyond the limits of death and time.
And so the chieftains will worry less about the power shifts, and you will worry less about their plans to replace you.
While the main supporters will not trust you or your family simply,
... Keychain can consider the motivational interests of all of you:
Account that staying with your family during a transition period gives them better opportunities to stay indoors ...
... because they know you and your relatives.
Also you will calculate, staying with the keys during a transition period will give you the best odds of staying on the throne.
It's an effective loop. Formed by accounts that are like confidence, but better.
The ruler gets a longer sentence, the keys will worry less, ...
... and everything is smooth because when the king died, the king lived.
Therefore, place the family in a high place in the military, trade, or political.
Not to mention the "qualifications" because for your family being qualified.
They must work with your sights, so they know where the money comes from and how it is distributed.
Family relations with the keys keep everyone calm not only during the transition, ...
... But more importantly for you and the length of your rule: than before.
So even if you do not have any interest in marriage and you do not have love for children, however: get them.
Of course, the risk of family they too will overthrow you.
Many princes challenged their kings, if they were sure they did not mind the keys.
But nothing sure, you can only play luck, the ruler without a family more susceptible to competitors and rumors.
Remember, the keys are concerned with treasury security in general, not you in particular.
For them, a family of rulers is a safe investment.
Thus, your overthrow is the price you pay to buy a longer and safer family rule.
That is why: Families are very popular among the rulers and their main supporters.
The family is a tool to stay in power, just like any other country.